Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, and today not an entire more perfect story,
just something that you need to know right now.
The supreme court's about to hear a case that apparently could turn the
country's legislative maps upside down more perfect. Sean rums from,
he's going to take it from here.
Hello Jad Hello America. So let's start with some context.
Republicans controlled a lot of legislatures in 2010 and there was also a census
that year,
which meant that a whole lot of Republicans got to redraw a whole lot of
legislative maps, and a lot of those maps benefited Republicans.
Democrats do this too, but today's case,
Gill v Whitford is about a republican maneuver, a map in Wisconsin where,
for example, in 2012 Democrats got 53% of the vote,
but only 39% of the seats and Republicans made that happen by packing Democrats
into Super Democratic districts where their votes were essentially wasted.
And also by cracking Democrats into mostly Republican districts where their
votes were essentially wastage
in a move that could have a huge bearing on the future of American politics.
The Supreme Court on Monday agreed to take up an explosive case.
Whether lawmakers in Wisconsin's Republican led legislature went too far in 2011
when they redrew the state's electoral map to make it harder for Democrats to
win legislative races and we'll makes the Supremes
court case all the bigger.
A big deal right now is the timing.
This is the first time in more than a decade that it's going to take up the
question of drawing the lines for partisan gains, and this is Justin Levitt.
He teaches law at Loyola in Los Angeles.
It's going to do that right on the eve of everybody redrawing the lines
everywhere. Local districts, state districts,
Congressional districts after the census in 2020 all sorts of different bodies
will redraw all sorts of different lines and this case will help decide how and
where and if the court can crack this nut,
it'll be solving one of the biggest and baddest and oldest abuses of power in
our democracy. It goes back to before there was an America.
So there were problems with rotten boroughs in England,
which were essentially districts with no people in them that nevertheless
collected representatives in this country in America.
The allegations go in these, these are also contested all the way back.
The allegations are that Patrick Henry tried to Gerrymander James Madison out of
the very first Congress from seats in Virginia because he was so upset with the
constitution.
The word itself comes from a in 1812 attempt to change the lines in
Massachusetts. It is named after governor of Massachusetts Elbridge Gary.
Um, and if you go to northeastern Massachusetts,
they will tell you passionately that it's called the Gary Mandarin,
not a gerrymander. Um,
that's something that people actually argue about get over.
So the allegations were that that Elbridge Gary created a district that snaked
around the Northern Cape and suburbs essentially. Uh,
it was ridiculed in a political cartoon at the time is looking more like a
salamander than a district. Okay. And the Portmanteau was born a Gary Mander.
And since that moment,
we've been living with this unfortunate word and this unfortunate problem.
And it turns out it's a really hard problem to solve love.
It says you can't just hit reset, draw some rectangles and call it a day.
That's not the way people live.
Nobody has ever bought a house because it fit the last perfect spot on the last
perfect square grid and the last perfect development in a square city in a
square county, in a square state.
The way we live is sloppy and messy and organic.
See that's, I find that interesting cause one of the,
one of the conversations people have about districts a lot of the times is like,
oh look at this district gets so crazy.
Yeah it's got a little tendril and then it's everywhere and it's over a year.
Right. But the truth is like if you look at like voting rights districts,
they'll do that to try and keep exactly populations together. Right. Totally.
I think the best example to look at here is Illinois Fourth Congressional
district. It looks like this weird jaw,
the skeletal jaw trying to like eat lake Michigan and she's like, oh no,
people actually call it the earmuffs.
And I ain't think earmuffs because it's a horizontal.
So if you flipped it that way, they look like earmuffs,
like two big chunks connected by basically this string [inaudible] it looks
really tacky. It's running up a highway.
But this was drawn by Democrats to unite.
Too similar, but geographically, you know,
apart a Latino district, right.
And to create some sort of cohesive block and it's actually,
if you look at it that way, it's a very good helpful district. Yeah, it gives,
it gives that community a voice. Right. So in the end,
the question is how do you distinguish between what's giving a community a voice
and what's straight up scandalous cheating.
It all starts with designing districts around real communities that have
something in common with each other.
It turns out that's really hard to do when you're a legislator focused intently
on the next election. And that's why time and time again,
gerrymandering has ended up in front of the Supreme Court of the United States.
The nine justices in DC have to do what congress doesn't really care to.
The constitution does not require the Fox to guide the Hanover.
This is just a Stevens back in 2004
partisan gerrymandering like the English rotten borough enables representatives
to choose their constituents rather than vice versa.
It is an invidious undemocratic and unconstitutional practice.
The case was VIF versus jubilee or is the last time the supreme court dealt with
partisan gerrymandering and Justice Kennedy in Veith versus jubilee or basically
you legal community of America need to solve this for us or we are in big
trouble.
I don't recall legislators talking about what neutral standards ought to be.
Now we have in our own jurists who talk about conflict do contiguity
geographical compactness,
but I just don't think we have a a large source on which to draw.
We knew about numbers when one person, one vote,
but beyond that it seems to me that we're at sea
and the justice is objectively looked at, see,
trying to fix this in veith versus Juba Layer. These are people who love rules.
They love tests,
so they came up with a whole bunch and no one could agree on any of them.
They're looking at the big statewide picture versus the local little picture.
They were using racial standards from the voting rights act and not,
it was like a hot mess of social science and Kennedy could see this and what he
said is sitting in the middle as he often is the most powerful man in the
country and by many stretches the courts should be in this business.
Yes,
but I haven't heard a standard that lets us decide how much is too much yet.
So give me some,
it was as public a plea to lawyers to bring cases to help him work through the
appropriate test. As I think anybody has ever seen.
It was sort of like this public challenge,
like who out there can solve this and now may finally have a solution.
Allow me to introduce the efficiency gap for me,
the efficiency gap gap for me,
the efficiency gap is essentially this relatively simple math equation for
measuring partisan gerrymandering.
The idea is if the justices wants to know,
was this district fairly drawn or are some legislators up to no good?
All they have to do is grab a calculator in a few numbers and Bam,
they get their answer.
Two political scientists came up with it and then a bunch of mathematicians
weighed in on it and one of them was professor moon. Do Chin,
you can call me moon or professor DJ. She works for Tufts University in Boston.
I do geometry topology group theory and dynamics,
so a little bit of everything across the maths spectrum. Just as a heads up,
what follows does acknowledge the existence of a math spectrum.
Moon coauthored a paper titled a formula goes to court,
which is essentially what's happening here.
The Supreme Court's going to consider whether this efficiency gap formula passes
muster.
Is this equation a reasonable standard for measuring partisan gerrymandering and
the efficiency gap formula does that in a couple of different ways.
Most importantly,
by measuring what's called wasted votes and wasted votes, by definition,
they are the number of votes that you got minus 50% if you won.
In other words, they're the votes that you wasted while winning.
So if Republicans got 60% in a district,
the wastage would be 10 okay. Okay. So, so if I got 10 votes,
but only five I wasted five or there all the votes if you lost.
So in that same district,
the Democrats got 40% and so that was 40% wasted because it didn't go towards
electing a democrat. Right. Okay.
So wastage for the losing side is basically all of the votes in a race where you
lost. Yeah. That's how wastage works.
And then the efficiency gap is quite simply,
you take all the wasted votes for a across the entire state,
all the wasted votes for B,
and you take the difference as a proportion of the total turnout. That's it.
That's it. That's the efficiency. Yeah. It's just like subtraction. That's it.
It's party A's, wasted votes minus party B's,
wasted votes divided by the total number of people who voted.
That gives you a number that measures gerrymandering.
It's it's addition and subtraction with a smattering of division.
It is so not scary.
So Republican wasted votes minus Democrat wasted votes divided by the total
number of overall votes. Yep. That's, that's the efficiency gap.
That's what we're trying to measure here. Yeah.
Why would that work as a measuring of gerrymandering?
So let's take a look at purple state like Wisconsin,
where you know you have Democrats winning and you have Republicans winning and
they're both wasting votes. They're both winning elections, losing elections,
and in each and every one of those races,
they're wasting votes because of a wasted vote.
Is anything over 50 if you won,
if 50% and anything you lost if you lost, right?
So wastage is happening across the board,
but theoretically it's happening on both sides.
So all of the wasted you should be canceling out in Wisconsin,
we have this picture where Democrats won 53% of the vote,
but only one 39% of the seats.
So Democrats were wasting a lot more than Republicans. Tons more.
And that might mean that there's sort of this pattern of wasted votes across the
entire state. The entire map might've been drawn to favor one side. Oh.
So is that like if you plug in the numbers in the equation, you,
if you get a big number that means lots of wasted,
you get a little number that means zero. Is that,
is that essentially it or is it something like that? Nailed it. Really? Yeah.
Oh yeah. That's cool. Yeah. So it literally is like two, two,
two, two, two, two, two poop. Oh, wasted. You know what I mean? It's like,
is it like that? Yeah, but there's actually a way that we don't need the two to,
to the moon's got an even easier way to understand this efficiency.
Get a shortcut or you can tell me what it is.
Do you want to know what is right now? No. After the break, after the break
[inaudible]
it's from Washington, from snap, snap,
Dakota live walks Nashville Wyman theater Friday,
March 16th and I'm bringing the best windows in the world last Friday,
laugh some more amazing night out. And yes, she's coming.
The funniest woman in the world. Jen Kober,
lady forest, Jen POBA rocks a brand new story.
Get tickets at snap judgment. That Org.
I've never gotten applause for it before. If you guys could call my mom,
that'd be awesome. She's still passed.
This is more perfect. M Jam. And we're out here with Sean Ramez from a,
we're talking about the ancient problem of gerrymandering and how um,
a solution may be about to fly into the supreme court on the gleaming wings of
math. You mentioned that there was a, there was a short, short
yeah. Yeah. You know,
if you don't like the math that we were doing a little bit deficiencies gap. Um,
professor do chin gave me this,
this sort of handy work around that'll probably make it a lot easier, um,
to understand the whole wasted vote thing. Cool.
It just involves comparing how many votes you got in a race to how many seats he
got in that same race.
All you have to do is take your vote margin and double it.
Efficiency gap tells you that should be your seat margin.
So you got 53% of the votes, let's say.
So that's a margin of 3% over halfway. Double it.
You should get 56% of the seats. Huh? If you get,
try this with me now you get 60% of the votes, so how many seats should you get?
Okay, so I got 60% of the vote. I need 50% to win,
so I to subtract that off, I got 10% left and doubled.
That's 20% and then I add back the original 50% I won and that
70% of the seats, you got it. But why not?
Just why not just 60% why did I double it? So that's an excellent question.
And what these guys have a kind of complicated answer to that.
Although it's interesting, they say, well, if you look at elections,
doubling the margin is what actually tends to happen. They claim
these guys, professor do Chin Means Stephanopoulos and muggy.
The dudes who came up with the efficiency gap,
what they say is when you look at elections across the country and compare how
many votes the winning right?
It gets to how many seats the winning party gets.
The winners tend to get some extra seats. This idea is called a seat bonus.
The idea that if you win by a little,
you should get a cushion in your governing majority. So it's like what?
Our system is kind of funky. Let's, let's roll with it.
And here we baked the funk into the, into the formula we baked in the funk.
I love it. That should be the subtitle. His genius of branding, right?
So they're taking something descriptive. This is what actually happens.
And then they're turning it around and something normative,
which says this is what should happen. Huh? So, well, let's look at,
let's look at Wisconsin.
The court said that Jerry Mandarin quote did in fact prevent Wisconsin Democrats
from being able to translate their votes into seats as effectively as Wisconsin
Republicans. So it was constant.
In 2008 dems get 57% of the vote.
So what percent of seats should they get?
This is according to the math we just did. Yep, you can do it. Okay. 57 ditch.
The 50 I got seven times two is 14 plus the original 50 a what?
Six 64% of the seats. You got it. Exactly. God,
I'm just so nervous now that I'll get it wrong. I have this effect on people.
Okay,
well instead in 2008 they get 52% and so that suggests that viewed through the
lens of efficiency gap, things are stacked against them by quite a bit. Okay?
Right? And so that's how this works.
It becomes only a way to compare your vote margin to your seat margin.
Now, Moon's feeling about all of this, the efficiency gap, the shortcut,
it's a good start, but it's just the start. I, you know,
I really respect the effort to take something so complicated and boil it down
into a single number,
but it fundamentally can't be done that simply because people are way more
complicated than just one number. We are, we are geography,
we are history or race. We're so many things.
You're going to need a few different metrics at once.
And the fear is that that's what the court's been allergic to is if you have
several different metrics,
how do you combine them and how do you decide when enough is enough?
By good fortune. We're now finally in a position, you know,
it's been a long time that partisan gerrymandering keeps being like the can
keeps being kicked down the road by the court.
Good news is they may have sort of postponed and delayed just long enough that
now we have some really good alternatives.
So one of the most promising things that's coming down the pike is the use of
computers for people dreamed of this for decades,
but computing power just hasn't been nearly ready to contend with the big data
of the redistricting problem.
That's because we're doing some phenomenally complicated common rhetoric's.
We've got this coming to torics. That's what matters.
That's what mathematicians call the art of counting. Oh,
the supreme court isn't quite at Kombucha torics but if Justice Kennedy likes
the efficiency gap,
the court's decision could dramatically change the way states draw lines.
And if the court can embrace this standard moons,
hoping it will go for others down the road,
ones that more fully consider all the kinds of connections that make up a
community.
And there are just phenomenally many ways to break down millions of people into
dozens of districts. If you just enumerate all the possibilities,
that's the biggest data you're going to find bigger than medical problems,
bigger than astronomical problems.
So asking a computer to really understand all the possibilities has been out of
reach.
But what's happened recently is both computing power and the algorithms used to
study this have been getting better and better. And um,
folks have understood how to constrain that search space more.
So what we're moving towards is a time when we'll be able to cut down the space
of possibilities that you have to search. And at the same time,
computers will be getting more powerful until those meet in the middle.
And computers can really see all the possibilities.
So when we're saying these numbers are,
are too big for mathematicians to even wrap their heads around,
we need computers. Oh no other way around. Mathematicians are very comfortable.
Why are you even comfortable with infinity?
It's the computers that have had to catch up. Oh, sorry. Okay.
So when we're saying the computers need to catch us, right,
how do we expect nine Supreme Court justices to get it right?
Well now here's the thing, right?
So what happens when computers can really explore the space of possibilities is
that they can build a bell curve of the properties of all the different maps.
So computers are going to do it for us.
Create maps upon maps upon maps.
That together will give us an idea of what a district should look like.
And then you'll look at Wisconsin's actual plans the legislature enacted and
you'll see where it falls on the bell curve.
Is it in the nice meaty part in the middle or is it an outlier that's just out
along the tail of the bell curve?
That's pretty persuasive and that's a kind of outlier analysis that should be
pretty comfortable for courts because they do this all the time for other kinds
of, um, legal standards. What does a perfect district look like?
What is something that is just that anyone,
regardless of political ideology could look at and say, Oh yeah, that's fair.
Yeah, good question. I mean,
so it's fun to do the roar shack blot version of detecting gerrymanders where
you, you know, in fact,
one of the things that my group is working on is like a swipe left swipe right
app for voting districts. You're going to see a district,
a little bit of information decide if you think it looks hot or not.
That's hilarious. That's great. So you have that,
can I play a coming up coming right here for congressional districts? Exactly.
We're calling it gerrymander without the e. You got it.
Great. So I mean that's always going to be fun, but um,
just that contour isn't always showing you what's really going on.
It's not just the outline, it's also where the people are and how they're split,
right?
It's the guts of the district and not just as a boundary that's got a lot of
information about its legitimacy. Um, so we're,
we're trying to throw a lot of 20th and even 21st century math at the district
rendered as a graph or a network and we think that's gonna produce some new
insights before that happens.
Does the Supreme Court have to say in this Gilby Whitford case, hey,
partisan gerrymandering is wicked unconstitutional. Well,
the court has already told us that partisan gerrymandering is,
is just equitable that they can,
they can throw out plans as partisan gerrymanders they just don't know how yet.
Huh. Right.
And so this case came up with efficiency gap as it's centerpiece in the future.
Cases may come up with outlier analysis as their centerpieces that they're going
to be more than one bite at this apple.
I regard efficiency gap as a great step towards convincing courts not to be
scared of adjudicating partisan gerrymanders. It's a,
it's a really good opening salvo. Great.
Well thank you so much for all your time.
I can't wait to download gerrymander and meet my next favorite district.
Right? That's right. Great, great talk
John Rahm's for Supreme Court audio in the show is from OEA,
a free law project in collaboration with the legal information institute at
Cornell.
Leadership support for more perfect is provided by the Joyce Foundation.
Additional funding is provided by the Charles Evans Hughes Memorial Foundation.
I'm Jen. I Boone. Rod more perfect. We'll be back next week.
Oh.